to present the Oscar for I'm sorry art
direction an Oscar winner whose art went
in two directions this year as actress
and screenwriter of Sense and
Sensibility please welcome the doubly
blessed and troubling nominated Emma
Thompson
thanks oh mighty one
ladies and gentlemen picture if you will
a perfectionist professor of art history
and architecture with the imagination of
Picasso the infinite precision of a
brain surgeon the stamina of Nancy
Reagan and the capacity to create an
entirely believable new world that is a
great art director it's sickening the
nominees for best art direction of a
motion picture are Apollo 13 art
direction by Michael Coren bliss
set direction by Meredith Boswell babe
art direction by Roger Ford set
decoration by Carrie Brown a little
princess art direction by beau Welch set
decoration by Cheryl classic restoration
art direction by Eugenio vanity
Richard the third art direction by Tony
burro
and the Oscar goes to
eugenio's energy for restoration
thank you very much restoration is a
story of a man who finally is restored
by God after he follows his heart I did
follow my heart until here and I'm
grateful to God I'm also grateful to my
mentor to my mom who's here to the
Academy to Miramax and to everybody who
make possible restoration my only advice
is follow your heart thank you